[Musique]
nous sommes le 7 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département la perspective de la fusion
avec les hauts-de-seine et apparemment
pas du goût de tous les conseillers des
yvelines philippe brillault également
maire du chesnay s'y oppose fermement il
entend lancer une association de défense
des yvelines nous reviendrons avec lui
aussi dans un instant sur sa candidature
à l'investiture dans la troisième
circonscription des yvelines pour les
législatives
et puis le festival féminin pluriel qui
se propose de mettre en avant la
création féminine dans le spectacle
vivant est parrainée cette année par
sophia aram la comédienne originaire de
trappes reviendra sur ses attentes
autour de ce rendez vous prévus à partir
de la fin de ce mois de février bonsoir
philippe brillault pour soi vous êtes
maire les républicains du chesnay
conseiller départemental a également
nous avons décidé de vous recevoir
aujourd'hui pour évoquer celle ce
rapprochement cette fusion avec le
département des hauts-de-seine yvelines
hauts de seine c'est une décision que
vous n'appréciez pas spécialement je
vais aussi préciser pour les
téléspectateurs que nous avions prévu
d'organiser un débat aussi avec des
représentants du conseil départemental
que personne n'a souhaité venir défendre
sa position face à vous ce sera donc une
interview avec vous seuls sur ce plateau
expliquez-nous déjà dans les grandes
lignes pourquoi refuser en tout cas vous
posez des questions vous interroger sur
ce rapprochement entre le département
des yvelines et le département des
hauts-de-seine de remercier d'autres
idées de ce face à face
je pense que s'il ya des absents c'est
parce que peut-être il y avait une gêne
pour répondre en fait je pense qu'il ya
trois éléments
premièrement le programme que nous
allions 2015 pour nous présenter tous
ensemble dans ce programme n'y avait pas
du tout de fusion alors que les
campagnes des départementales voilà
exactement alors qu' il y avait
obligatoirement déjà des idées entre les
deux présidents du 92 78
ensuite la méthode la méthode de la
communication à l'intérieur était là ou
pas et troisième pan c'est quels sont
les avantages les inconvénients de cette
fusion je crois que c'est pour cela que
aujourd'hui je suis engagé à dire les
choses même si je pense que beaucoup le
pensent mais ne peuvent pas le dire ou
ne veulent pas le dire quelques voix qui
se sont élevées au sein du conseil
départemental des yvelines je pense à
yves vandewalle par exemple ou encore
christine boutin qu elle soit si ce
rapprochement
vous avez des mots très durs me l'avait
déclaré lors de vos voeux plus on
rajoute des couches plus on sort du fric
de votre poche vous à dire essayer à
l'assemblée présente ce soir là je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les électeurs ont besoin
de clarté de transparence on va tout ce
qu'on vit en ce moment l'actualité
montre bien que les politiques doivent
être clairs sur ce qu'il propose sur ce
qu'ils font et ce qu'ils ne font pas je
crois que c'est pour ça que moi je ne
suis pas d'accord car si j'avais su que
nous engagions dans une fusion des
départements
je n'aurais pas adhéré à cette équipe
unique
je crois que c'est ça qui est important
c'est de dire aux gens ce que l'on veut
faire
donc la fusion c'est tout simplement le
président du 92 qui avec la métropole du
grand paris avait besoin peut-être de
sortir de cette petite couronne et
d'aller chercher un départements de
grande couronne les yvelines qui sont
venus s 92 et un président du 78 qui
n'avaient pas forcément pensé mais à qui
on a proposé peut-être un certain nombre
d'intérêts d'intérêts politiques
d'intérêt de management autour de la
vallée de la seine qui est quand même
son grand dada
pour vous c'est des enjeux particuliers
de personnes et aux biens personnels là
aujourd'hui font que attention on se
retrouve dans ce sens des décisions de
deux personnes et pas des décisions des
assemblées ni des décisions d 1 million
400 mille habitants des yvelines qui en
plus ont dû faire face à une
augmentation de la taxe foncière 66% 125
euros par foyer avec des baisses de
dotations pour les familles
pour les crèches aux autres je pense
qu'il y à vraiment la toux qui échappent
complètement et aux élus et aux
habitants ce qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui
pour vous réconcilier avec cette idée de
rapprochement ce serait une consultation
un référendum auprès des deux
populations yvelines et autres set
d'abord c'est qu'on reste dans l'idée
que la fusion qui est aujourd'hui qui
pointe son nez était présenté comme une
mutualisation la mutualisation c'est
partager des moyens auxquels qu'on ne
peut pas répondre dans le souci de
l'économie la mutualisation est une
bonne idée
un premier budget f1 il même deuxième
budget puisque pour cette année pour
2017 pour le pays cet établissement qui
a été créée entre les deux institutions
entre les images et les hauts-de-seine
l'enveloppé 2 c'est dérisoire par
rapport au budget d'un département mais
d'un peu plus de 13 millions d'euros
pour financer notamment l'entretien
l'exploitation du réseau routier ou
encore l'archéologie préventive quelques
quelques missions qui sont mutualisés
balle alors à la fin de l'année dernière
on a créé une boîte qui est un
établissement public dans lequel on
transfère pour les deux départements des
compétences l'archéologie l'adoption et
les routes mais on transfère aussi des
recettes compétentes et après les
sénatoriales parce que bien sûr on ne
fait rien pendant les élections on
transférera temps on transférera en
septembre ou en octobre la totalité des
compétences ou le président de cette
nouvelle boîte et patrick devedjian est
pas pierre bédier donc ça veut dire que
le voyez j'ai découvert par une note
auprès du personnel que l'on va
transférer le personnel à guyancourt
dans dans un immeuble de location donc
ça veut dire que en octobre à l'été
prochain
2017 on transfère les 700 personnes qui
travaillent sur versailles sur
différents sites à guyancourt dans un
immeuble en location soit disant pour
revenir à versailles dans un nouveau ni
meubles mais pas du tout en fait on a
transféré tout le monde a eu recours
septembre octobre
une fusion valait pas une fille ans
parce que c'est une décision
gouvernementale
mais je dirai tout le monde dans la
boîte d'un nouvelle boîte et puis
finalement payé publie donc vous allez
défendre le département des yvelines
avec cette association vous allez lancer
mais oui mais oui pourquoi parce qu en
fait plus on augmente le mammouth
plus on s'éloigne de la proximité des
gens or aujourd'hui il faut garder une
proximité
il faut garder une politique nationale
en diminuant les couches donc diminuer
les couches
on a fait l'intercommunalité skis pour
l'intercommunalité le département il ya
choix entre les deux
on a fait une métropole c'est à dire que
les gens de plus en plus ce sont les
couches et quand on a critiqué mon
candidat françois fillon de dire qu'on
va supprimer des fonctionnaires
en fait on va supprimer des postes dans
ces assemblées et c'est pas autre chose
que d'arrêter l'inflation l'emploi qui
va repartir avec des emplois publics
c'est sûrement paul retour de l'économie
future vous avez évoqué françois fillon
vingt et un vent c'est un petit peu au
cours de cet entretien pour évoquer un
deuxième point avec vous et on l'espère
on verra sur cette question de
départements à travers un débat dans les
prochains mois sur sur cette antenne
on va évoquer les législatives parce que
henri guaino ne sera pas soutenue par
les républicains dans la troisième
circonscription dans cette
circonscription qu'il détenait au tout
au cours de ce mandat notamment pour
c'est le propos à l'encontre de sa
formation politique vous avez fait acte
de candidature pour obtenir
l'investiture dans cette troisième
circonscription
qu'est ce qui vous motive candidat à
l'investiture parce qu'on a besoin de
relayer ce que les gens attendent
on voit bien le malaise qu'il peut y
avoir aussi bien dans les gens de gauche
que dans une jambe droite ce qui ne
faisait pas henri guaino vous voulez par
henri guaino tour de termes et guaino a
plein de qualités c'est un type qui est
instruit haute mais il n'est pas sur le
terrain
il n'écoute pas les gens comment
voulez-vous à l'assemblée nationale
proposer des lois qui ne sont pas en
rapport avec les attentes des gens
aujourd'hui moi je considère que ma
candidature et celle je pense de
l'expérience et de la proximité des gens
il faut absolument que dans quelques
mois on est un renouveau dans notre pays
avec des présidentielles pour lequel
aujourd'hui on voit pas très clair
un même si j'ai mon candidat et que j'y
crois et puis une assemblée qui va
devoir ou faire le contrepoids d'une
présidentielle que nous ne savons pas ou
alors va être je dirais l'élément moteur
du président de la république donc
vraiment il ya beaucoup de cas de figure
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut des gens
costauds solides
il ya un peu de gars sûrs physique envie
de la voir cette investiture
après vos propos justement contre par
exemple cette idée de fusion de
départements la tolérance et psion c'est
une circonscription qui est gelé c'est à
dire qu'elle est trop belle et trop
belle mais surtout très compliqué ça
prenait toujours lui les gens qui
arrivaient vous
s'il allait ou par l'avion entame on a
eu beaucoup de transport en commun pour
régler soi 3e circonscription et puis
là-bas on se dit qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire
si la droite veut séduire les gens il
faut qu'elle change de techniques pour
qu'elle change de méthode c'est des gens
de terrain qui doivent y aller c'est la
raison pour laquelle je fais avec deux
candidats
vous parlez de votre candidat c'est
françois fillon françois fillon sans
hésitation malgré les nouvelles
révélations qui vont encore arriver
demain soit dame attendait révèle des
indemnités de licenciement autour de
pénélope fillon mais voulait qu'on en a
qu'on en sorte plein sur tout le monde
il faut arrêter tout ça maintenant
parlons vraiment de ce que l'on évite de
faire d'un programme est de pouvoir
séduire les gens par la volonté d'être
capable de faire si aujourd'hui françois
fillon n'a pas démontré sa capacité à
faire et sa volonté de résister alors je
sais pas ou sur les autres la suite pour
vous vous attendez cette décision à la
dernière minute pour cette investiture
en mémoire est ce que vous serez
candidat si vous ne l'avez pas là mais
bien sûr même sans investiture
bien sûr donc contre votre famille
politique pas du tout qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une famille aujourd'hui une
famille c'est quelqu'un qui est
solidaire de ses membres s'ils sont
solidaires de ses membres ils me
demanderont investiture merci félibrige
est revenu sur ce plateau on va quitter
le monde de la politique quoique
puisqu'on va parler maintenant du
festival féminin pluriel pour parler de
ces femmes engagés dans la création
culturelle et à la marraine cette année
et c'est sophia aram nous l'avons
rencontrée c'est au micro de camille
lambert
nous sommes la maison elsa triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pour
le lancement du festival féminin pluriel
nous sommes en compagnie de sophia aram
marraine de cette première édition du
festival bonjour sofia alors du coup un
petit mot sur ce festival pourquoi avoir
accepté d'être marraine c'était
important pour vous alors oui parce que
c'est un sujet qui me tient à coeur
la création la place des femmes dans le
milieu de la culture c'est des sujets
auxquels je suis évidemment enfin pour
des raisons évidentes mais pas que je
pense que c'est un sujet dont on doit
tout ce qu'on doit tous appropriée c'est
vraiment un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur parce que j'ai
l'impression que ces dernières années on
a tendance à reculer et la question de
la place des femmes dans notre société
passe vraiment près par la culture et on
vous en sortie également très passionné
1 pendant le pendant la présentation
pendant la conférence de presse
ça c'est un défaut que j'ai j'espère que
je m'emballe mais parce que c'est un
sujet qui est ça me paraissait tellement
évident l'égalité homme femme pour moi
ce n'était plus un sujet pour moi
c'était un acquis et puis je me rends
compte que les les préjugés ont la vie
dure et qu' il faut encore se battre
et quand il s'agit de se battre il faut
sortir les griffes et puis il faut y
aller il faut prendre la place et c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de la parité
hommes femmes dans l'économie avec
l'égalité salariale évidemment la santé
avec liv et j'ai ce genre de choses mais
assez peu dans la culture au final c'est
important aussi de mettre l'accent là
dessus mais bien sûr mais les chiffres
qui ont été données au monde la
présentation de tout ce qui était mis en
place sont assez affligeant c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression enfin quand on va
dans les écoles de théâtre quand on va
dans l'est dans tous les cours de
théâtre
y a que des filles et puis à la sortie
quand on voit tout ce qui est
programmation culturelle
tous les artistes on voit des mecs des
metteurs en scène comme des chefs
d'orchestre sommes des chorégraphes
sommes assurés où sont passés les
gonzesses dans tout ça où est ce qu'on
les a perdus n'ont qu'à un moment il
faut il faut aller les chercher il faut
leur dire que leur place elle est là il
faut y aller moi si c'est ce dont elles
ont envie il faut pas s'excuser d'être
là vous l'avez un petit peu évoquée avec
cette idée qui est un petit peu une
certaine censure en fait une auto
censure on le fait qu'on n'ose pas
peut-être allez allez là dedans
quelle place selon vous où sont les
femmes actuellement dans ce spectacle
vivant c'est difficile à dire je parle
de ce que je connais c'est à dire que
dans l'humour par exemple moi je suis
humoriste donc je parle de ce que je
connais est ce que j'ai pu remarquer
programme c'est que certains sujets les
femmes ne se les approprient pas et que
quand par exemple pour parler moi je
fais un spectacle qui parle de politique
et par ça surprend parce que c'est un
sujet dans lequel on n'attend pas les
femmes on attend que les femmes viennent
parler de ça j'ai du mal à trouver un
mec que j'ai de la cellulite à la
maternité mon accouchement était
douloureux tout ça et moi je m'en fout
en fait c'est pas mis sujet du verset
sujet qui intéresse peut-être plein de
gens mais moi non je vois pas pourquoi
ce serait la chasse gardée des mecs de
parler de politique de parler de
religion de parler de liberté
d'expression de laïcité et il faut que
ce soit quelque chose de réparer
il n'y a pas de sujet qui appartient
particulièrement aux aurait pas de sujet
féminin exclusivement un dernier petit
mot sur peut-être des femmes qui vous
inspirent qui vous ont inspiré il y en a
il y en a vraiment beaucoup après le
problème c'est que c'est que ça date un
peu c'est que si on parle de simone de
beauvoir
c'est un peu délicat mais non je parle
il ya des tas de femmes qui est qui
m'ont qui m'ont encouragé
il ya aussi des femmes qui m'ont qui ont
exaspéré
je pense que c'est c'est en réaction à
certaines femmes un jour une fille m'a
dit je faisais de l'improvisation
théâtrale à l'époque et je démarrais et
elle m'a dit parce qu'elle me trouvais
un petit peu fragile une petite chose
comme ça et je me dis ma fille pour
réussir dans ce métier faut des couilles
et l'or comme c'était pas au programme
la greffe de testicules j'avais pas du
tout de ça comme ambition dans ma vie je
m'étais dit que j'allais faire avec mes
ovaires et que ça n'allait pas du tout
me poser de problèmes dans la vie et au
contraire ça va et ça a été un vrai
moteur pour moi de prouver que auquel
j'ai pas de couilles mais je vais y
aller quand même très bien mais je pense
que ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup par bercy beaucoup sophia aram
merci encore voilà pour ce joli mot de
la fin qui sera aussi le mot de la fin
de cette édition du 7 8 les invités en
et vous demain aux horaires habituels
très belle soirée
[Musique]